das hier könnte die einfachste Pasta
sein die ich je gekocht habe und die
Hauptzutat ist Tomatenmark wichtig
außerdem noch Knoblauch Chili und fürs
Auge Petersilie los geht's ordentlich
Olivenöl nudelwalz nudelwald wir müssen
die nudelwalze Salzen Nudelwasser
ordentlich salzen knoblauchzehens
Märchen Knoblauch rein und dann wird es
auch schon Zeit Chili hinzuzugeben und
direkt hinterher unsere Hauptzutat das
Tomatenmark so das Braten wir schön mit
an und das ist wirklich der Inbegriff
von aus wenig viel machen unsere Nudeln
kochen parallel und wir nehmen von ihnen
eine wunderschöne stärkehaltige Kelle
Nudelwasser geben die oben drüber alles
schön miteinander verbinden und ihr
merkt es entsteht wirklich direkt eine
echte Soße jetzt stark bleiben wir
nehmen die Knoblauchzehen raus sie haben
ihren Dienst getan die Soße ist mit
Knoblauch aromatisiert und wir wollen
einfach so eine wunderschöne einfache
Soße haben wenn alles zu einem geworden
ist geben wir unsere Nudeln dazu direkt
aus dem Topf mit Nudelwasser dran die
Magie nimmt ihren Lauf eine wunderbare
Pasta wird geboren wir verbinden das
ganze wow
Probleme so viel mehr als man den